okay everybody we are doing another
10 bullet points from our startup
founder checklist this is a checklist
that every founder needs to just
basically work their way through to make
sure you understand all the
opportunities problems pitfalls
uh and wisdom that has been hard-earned
in the last 50 years of startup science
uh and alchemy and anecdotal experiences
and we've worked really hard building
this list the audience has done a great
job sending us feedback producers at
this week in startups.com if you want to
send feedback to the producers
and you can see these checklists anytime
you want at this week in startups.com
checklist
if you want to take the startup founder
checklist and you want to remix it
change it edit it you can cut and paste
it just link back to the original and
say hey i'm riffing on you know what
jason and his team did here with their
checklist and you can you can change it
you can update it you can do whatever
you want with it as long as it's like
not commercial uh and you link back and
give credit okay so uh you know like a
creative commons license type thing on
this we in our first episode did the
qualities of a winning founder basically
what's inside of you
then in episode two
we really drill down into business
models because your business model is
your outcome and your business model
defines your investors your business
model defines your team your business
model defines your product and your
marketing you gotta know your business
model episode two critically important
and one of those things founders don't
think about early enough
episode three understanding delighting
customers man that's what it's all about
at the end of the day after you pick
your business model and
you know you have the qualities of a
winning founder you're gonna have to
delight some customers but in order to
like those customers you need a product
and that's what we're talking about
today i call it the startup flywheel uh
so welcome to episode four of the
startup checklist you can view the
checklist again at this week in
startups.com
checklist right we try to do everything
really simple that's my url obsession
this week in startups.com
discord slash meetups slash
book clubs slash checklist all of those
go
to uh the places you would think
so today again this week in startups.com
checklist if you want to follow along
and we have a youtube channel where we
put some supplemental graphics up on the
screen or you can listen to this in
audio up to you and maybe you're biking
if you're on your e-bike please don't
watch youtube you get the idea so
let's get into it i don't want to uh
belabor the point here i want to get
right to uh the
core of this issue so
the first uh item on our checklist which
is going to be number 31 right the
previous ones are on the website uh is
do you know what problem or problems
your product solves
most great products solve an acute
problem now some people say you know
they're vitamins not painkillers
so what problem does netflix solve when
it's entertaining you what problem does
instagram solve it's kind of hard to
frame those products entertaining
products
as solving a problem unless you say
boredom uh which is actually a problem
for some people
uh but we're here talking about uh the
majority of startups i would say 80 or
90 really fall into the painkiller
they're removing some friction they're
they're solving a problem and they're
making people's lives
uh better by saving them time saving
them money or just getting rid of
friction and suffering in your life
you can phrase this as why does your
product exist
i like what problem does your product
solve or do you know what problem
problems your product solves a little
bit better
because what is your product exists
people tend to answer that question in
my experience when i ask it that way
they'll tend to give some answer with a
bunch of buzzwords
so let's just do some really really
simple um
answers here
shopify
makes entrepreneurship easy on the
internet it makes it easy to start a
store shopify makes it easy to start a
store it's
shopify makes it cheap and easy to start
a store
shopify makes it fast and cheap to start
a store on the internet really really
simple problem being solved there
creating a store on the internet what
previously was expensive and previously
was time consuming uber
it gets you a ride quickly and cheaply
the end and if you notice in both of
those
speed and price come up
this is one of the truisms of delighting
customers if you save them time or you
save them money they're going to love
you if you do both you're going to be a
hero
superhuman
it just makes you get through your email
inbox faster it helps you get to inbox
zero
and inbox zero is hard for busy people
so now you have to ask yourself well how
big are those problems for your
customers
well
if you're in email for more than two or
three hours a day if you can make it
faster for me
that's gonna add up let's say i was in
my email box for three hours a day
that's actually close to true for a lot
of venture capitalists sadly so you're
in your email box for three hours a day
that's about 200 minutes
you make it 10
but 10
faster you're saving me 20 minutes a day
you're saving me 100 minutes a week
you're saving me
5 000 minutes a year
that's a lot of time you're talking
about close to 100 hours of somebody's
time it is enormous so
um getting a ride quicker you ever try
to get a yellow cab when you're in
brooklyn or try to get a yellow cab to
go to brooklyn this is hard stuff at
least when i was in new york in the 90s
so i would say
these are problems that are incredibly
incredibly acute in other words they're
intense and they're real and they're
hard so
if you uh want to compete with uber or
superhuman today you're going to have to
say well hmm
you're not going to say can i be faster
than gmail now you got to say can i be
faster
than superhuman you're not going to say
can i be faster than in more
and cheaper and better than a yellow cab
now you're going to be better than a
lift an uber and a yellow cab
this is what entrepreneurship
capitalism and the race to win customers
is all about and it's why america and
democracy combined with capitalism is
such a great system it's the worst
system in the world
in some people's minds but it's the best
system we've ever come up with certainly
better than communism and socialism uh
here andeth iran